s unto it roing around I turn this elbow
in
Pro the
[Music]
last as I come around
I get there
[Music]
there's boom now W pop on the side and
again martially your goal would be
this
[Music]
all right so on our Gateway iido
videos um we receive a a question from
one of the people that are either
following us on Facebook or that is
training uh with us from across the
globe um we entertain it here for you
that are here
because sometimes a group runs out of
angles and perspectives so we entertain
this so we had this one we I received a
question
onari um and we gave gave you guys that
problem uh to figure it out and that
didn't go so well okay so
um let us explain a few things on this
and hopefully you can take more the
methodology so that you can learn how to
learn um as I
said I don't we don't do futa to I don't
I don't do
it
um it's a interesting thing
uh I on that video that we
posted uh as I mentioned to another
person that asked how come I'm why do I
sometimes wear shorts and you know
because uh again the question comes from
the ferite mindset even though it was
done respectfully and in good spirit but
um it's it's that fedorite mindset
that somehow what you're working on is
is
symbolically metaphorically
institutionally
recognizable um where I would radically
disagree and go and say it's not it's
something intangible
unknowable and it's inside
you so I don't care what clothes I'm
wearing or with I'm wearing clothes
but
when on that day we were working on it
and I gave it to you guys remember
because I don't I don't do these
techniques and I gave it to you guys hey
figure out what's going on and what I
wanted you to do is figure out how would
you do this in a way that is consistent
with what we do here
okay and we resorted to the pushing
pulling thing right kind of forcing it
um and then like at the end I stood up
and go okay and then I showed it
different
way um why don't we do those techniques
because Kona which is anytime you have a
prescribed
um initiated energy cue to me that's
keona so anytime you're doing kihon waza
you're not doing self-defense
so going back to the fedorite mindset on
that video that I posted uh the original
post had uh futa doti is not what you do
when two guys grab you and it as I tried
to share it it got
denied so there there's the that little
ferite gatekeeper you've see and
um that
is that institutional mindset where
you're it's outside and there's a belief
that your kihon waza is uh selfdefense
and that is not my position that is what
our current podcast is on and so what is
kihon waza to me you know cut to the
chase of part three of the latest
podcast um kihon waza is a purification
ritual by which you want to understand
purification
is a return to an eternal returning
to the Genesis
act you're doing that in your body
energetically for not only reasons of
Health which would include psychological
Health um and physical health of course
but that's actually your duty as an as a
human
organism is to understand that Genesis
act and align yourself with it by being
an imager of God that is that is the
Imaging of God is the Genesis act so
that is what you're trying to do in
kihon Wasa so you're
taking uh yin and yang
aspects and you are in a way your
purification is about
reversing the the ACT and then redoing
it again so you start from your mundane
existence and you're going to work
through your Yin and yangong in a
reverse fashion back to the time space
prior to yinin yangong and then come
back into Yin and yangong that is what
kihon waza
does and it does it at all three levels
so it does it at the body level it does
it at the energetic level and it does it
at the the spiritual level that's what
Kon wat does and for the for that kind
of
purification you do not need 50 60
techniques you you one is
enough and when you understand it truly
you don't need a form you don't need a
prescription it could be it it doesn't
have to
beo it could
beo you see it doesn't matter what it is
just repeat
it you don't need many of them so that's
why we don't do here
fut there's no ferite prescription that
you need to do these for your next rank
rank again is external symbolic outside
you I don't care about that I care what
you can what what's
inside
so if you look at these
rituals and you understand as I've said
many times that while there is a
purification aspect to them they're not
going to
violate Marshall principle in the end
they're not going
to and I mentioned these two things
because if you understand the
purification
ritual you will know how to do futa doti
you you you know how it
goes but likewise because it is
concentric with Marshall principle if
you truly understand Marshall principle
you would also know how to do fut okay
and so not having done it not doing it
because we don't need it I understand it
first from the energetic point of
view and what you see when you look at
kihon waza is it is testing weak points
what or what is commonly manifested at
weak
points in somebody trying to learn the
purification
ritual your Kon waza variation is a
testing of those weef points so for
example kadori is going to test for
Corner organization
ation
[Music]
um is testing
for deltoid utilization shouldn't be
there katata is related
[Music]
to by increasing the amount of material
stressor on the distal end of the lever
so you would increase your skill Eddie
doy on the collar it's another weak
point Center Line going backwards
another weak
point s hij on the elbows you're testing
again for weak points connection points
Etc so when you get to F and you're
working with M you're looking at can I
keep the
organization necessary for the
purification
ritual with this m this amount of
resistance on the distal end of my lever
okay as I
surveyed remember I asked you to share a
video with me CU we don't do them uh I
watched the video and the instructor in
the video well respected welln very high
rank is just pushing pushing and pulling
and as I surveyed more people doing it
again all very high rank they're always
pushing and
pulling if you come to this from that
purification ritual there's a few things
that you could use to tell you what to
do and what not to do there's no pushing
and pulling in the purification
ritual there's no pushing and pulling in
iido so that's just
wrong if you look at Yin Yong the
you can't Yong into yangong space that's
a Yong Yong conflict you have to
harmonize yin and yang so pushing
someone is going to be a y yangong
[Music]
conflict as I saw people try to do the
technique they're not only pushing for
the throw but prior to that they're
pulling to set the throw up this is not
this is not in the ritual it's
incorrect it doesn't answer can you
still do iido with this much resistance
at the distal end of your
levers that answer is yes overpower it
that's not the
[Music]
ritual likewise as I said if you look at
things
martially as I watch the people that
push and pull in order to push and pull
you have to be in front of the
person now that there's two that means
I'm in the middle of the people two
people and this makes no sense when it
comes to multiple
attackers you always want to Stack
multiple attackers so they become one
line of attack not I'm flanked from both
sides that's that's the exact opposite
of Marshall sense
okay so we are going to look at this
technique in more detail not me just
standing up at the end of our grappling
class and go let me try it that's what
part one is we're going to look at this
from these points of view um and with
the aim of teaching you these points of
views so you can figure out if you so
wish the other fut C
okay okay part of your Kon waza as far
as a purification ritual is that it
works with
dichotomy um as you reverse the yin
Andy aspects back into the Genesis
act you are going to undo
dichotomy and what happens in every
single valid viable religious system is
they play with
dichotomy so outside will act like
inside down will act like up okay there
that this is why your greatest
religious um figures are always
subversive to the institution the
institution can't take that kind of
stuff okay so we have Shag in this
technique and as I watched uh all those
high ranking people do Shon they
actually did standard
Shon okay and in this technique you're
not going to do standard Shon you're
going to have the external aspect of
shon but you're using it more to throw
them backwards okay
not turn and do an angle cancellation
going forward and that's where the
biggest mistake is that I saw as people
did did standard
shag they brought themselves between the
two UK and then they remain in front of
the two and they have to push them okay
so if we
look
martially you have two people here come
grab okay they stay there now without
the grab okay so here I
am and as they move into standard shag
so you have you're you're going to see
that
okay back in that X
Vector so it makes no sense martially to
enter here in the middle of them you
would you would never do that even
though it looks like you got through on
that
side
but if you make one guy go here your
initial Emi is now not in the middle of
them and when you ten con you can see
that they're lined up now you guys see
that so I have to figure some way of not
putting myself in the middle which is
never right
okay and now we'll reverse engineer the
technique so I know he's going to go
this way and I know he's going to turn
this way
okay and I know that they're going to be
this
way and I know they're going to do a
back
rall so in order to do a back
breakfall I am not going to push them
got that I know they have to be falling
that way when I in does that make sense
so that is is more reason why I'm not
going to go
here do
this because now I'm pushing
[Music]
them so different from every single Sur
every my survey of what people are doing
I am going to take sh and not take him
forward I'm going to take sh Naga and
bring him backward
that's immediately going to
clear
my I'll do it again and so you can make
sure you see it so I'm going to make him
move past me which is always what you do
in
EDI martially for you to edem me he has
to be moving forward
so I make him go forward around me and
they hit each
other so different for what I've seen
I'm using him to hit
him instead of I go here come around and
then pull on him to hit Ron that's not
that's not
right okay so I know I'm doing that
here and then I know I'm doing koku ho
here on
him I've seen some are coming around gra
some are coming around the outside
that's not the lean for K
ho you need him to lean in in the body
lean for K ho is in not out
so don't come on the outside side here
don't come on the outside cuz he's going
to be leaning the other
way do it again so you can see don't
come on the
outside no you're not going to have it
what tends to happen is the UK will fix
himself for the technique he
knows that's not
right so we'll just look at him
if I want him to get hit by him I want
him deeper on him deeper in the kazushi
so I don't want to pull him into
this I'm going to leave him here and I'm
going to go
around because I'm not allowed to pull
not allowed to pull in Ika that's going
to be my outer
Del
so I'm going to leave him
here here so let's look at this hand I'm
going this way that's what I
want so just we'll take that hand okay
I'm going to turn his
elbow there's that
lean that's all the lean I need he's
caned inward that's what that's coku
ho as he goes back as he gets hit by the
other guy this hand is going to do the
same cooku projection we did in the last
um video so it's here it's going to
project after he gets hit by
Rod
so I send rodent around I turn this
elbow in
[Music]
Project the more you send Ronin around
the less
energy it takes for me to do cuz ronin's
hitting so let me show Ronin going
around this is what I'm
doing do it one more
time all right
round I do the same
thing
[Music]
it's
effortless
okay let's
try okay so now that we have the
trajectories let's look at the footwork
so he's going to go
around
here so I'm on the
side on the side
okay and in back because that is where
let go Tristan that is where CIO hole
happens in the back not in the front at
this angle in the back so that if needed
I can attack the leg
[Music]
okay be careful with the legs because it
depends on your UK skill okay but you
should always seek and see the leg
whether you're there or not okay so as I
come around I get there
there's all right
maybe one
[Music]
more yeah I won't do it
anymore but you'll see that I'm in that
same position okay so around boom
here so when you
enter he's going around you one
two there's the leg right
there he goes around you and I'm ining
[Music]
there
don't lose that final
C up don't lose this one your hand is
going to R
rotate and it's right here you feel
it it's not just that he's throwing that
this is going there
too
[Music]
here boom there it is right there let's
move off the
wall
[Music]
okay let's
go
for the viewer will start with the
regular position come over here
run okay so here don't cut outside
that's going to tilt his body this way
coku hole needs his body tilted this way
okay so not here you're going to go this
way you see so uh a tip you can use
always any time you need more English in
the elbow is you don't have to keep your
grip like that the intention of the UK
already happen so a very common one that
I see this on is um sual kiten so people
will start with their regular katat DOI
and it's very hard to get on the outside
you're now opening up the inner
deltoid but when you're going to do Soto
kiten you off or off your wrist back a
little you're going to turn it right on
the grab and now you can keep your elbow
underneath and get on the
outside so very similar here you want
more English so to speak on this
elbow and the more you start here the
less you can
get so if you start
here when you rotate you get more do you
see just just don't come all the way to
the outside it's all it's all on the
inside that's all the Tilt I need then I
would move myself into that
spot here there's the leg attack and I'm
close you should be doing cooku ho with
your upper
arm never with your lower
arm if you if you ever felt that it
would be a Tami or You' pass it
it so never on the upper arm it's going
to activate your outer tail
toy if your upper arm is what's in range
on his head neck area then there's your
leg was not available for the uh
deconstruction of the basic support okay
so he's coming around I get the English
that I get here that's all I need I come
around I enter boom there's the leg and
I'm on the upper arm my hands
turn here at the end don't cut here
don't smell it
here there's the C there and this CES
out that way and I
enter at the end
here so again you'll see you turn Palm
up here
this way boom pop
[Music]
turn
so I don't know if you've noticed this
about my C hle but I don't do the way
that we were probably shown so you have
this
10 I don't go me turn this stance is
very weak to me okay so as weak as as it
is if he pushes into
me that is how weak it is for me to
torque him as as much as it is unstable
against his push it is unstable for me
to
torque so
mine go
e ten con and I'm
inen in the back so when he pushes it
goes forward around me and then I
enter so my
10 after me is just so I could Ed me
again you
see
likewise I don't do it Ed me 10 con
because although I'm not in front I'm
not very stable laterally I have this
weird thing on my inner knee that's
injuring me over the decades if I I do
this as weak as I am if you were to push
on me that's how weak I am to use it for
torque but I also can't really
enter cuz my feet are far apart from
each
other versus the use of chisen TI I can
move enter feet together
enter okay so it's not just feet side by
side
she's
zti that's part of the ritual that
alignment of my midfoot vector and
letting the chi drop is part of the
ritual this is not it this is not
[Music]
it so watch How I do that okay right
coming around one
two one two okay and as he hits him and
energy is going to the
rear that creates Yin space and that's
where I
enter
boom now W pop on the side
and when do I
enter after it hit them and then going
that way don't get
greedy don't go
here
you're going let him hit you're going to
feel that pressure come off and you just
follow
it again martially your goal would be
this just to hit that inner leg okay all
right so clean up your ten
conom okay so let's now look at it
energetically so as he comes in my T in
is going to turn this
way this
way same thing on this
hand this
way right so as they come in my T in
turn
Okay the t turns this way then it's
going to go down and up that's when he
goes up so to the right down up it's up
okay and then it's going to come back to
the other way
back the other way and then down and now
you repeated the rotating spiraling
cross Genesis okay as opposed to right
here there's no spiraling rotating cross
in it okay so that's what I
feel complete the up complete the up
here you're you're
down complete the
up and then down at the
end start the turn I'm not seeing the
turn there so you start the turn boom
complete the up complete the up up up up
up up until it on its own goes down
that's where your Center goes
down if you don't complet up you're down
here on this guy on his chest that's
where you guys
are so watch my right hand pull straight
up straight up not enough when you turn
it it goes higher and now it can begin
its downward descent with the H
Bo again why this why do I short change
it cuz I'm breedy and I want to pushup
instead I want to do the
[Music]
energy
complete the up go okay so in order to
do the spiraling
cross with my
tanden you have to do my
Tenon and um you're going to probably
find cuz my people here found that it's
very difficult to do and the reason that
I am detecting is that you smell the
propulsion engine okay and then you go
for it so let me first note the
problem so he's going to go around me
and I'm going to go one you're going to
do this slight deviation
here and now you're going to
push from
here what I do instead is not go here
but all the way to
here then same please hold your
balance then I extend the up with the
hand rotation so we're here hand
rotation up they're falling and that's
where I can now enter because your
energy is going that
[Music]
way so I go
one two
three
three boom and follow their energy
boom
one
two not
here
three that completes the spiral rotation
of the H sending it ready to go back the
other
way and then down Okay so let's have you
guys try that go slow enough that you
can change what your instinct wants to
do there you go